Please,
stand up.
If you're able.
Thank you.
I want you to feel like I felt,
when I was getting sentenced.
It's August 17, 2012.
I’m handcuffed
and standing for four long hours
while the judge is reading my sentence.
You're in a small cage
and you're surrounded
by 10 prison guards in balaclavas.
There is also a guard dog
who is barking at you angrily
because the dog is trained
to be suspicious
towards people who smell like prison.
Even a nice little doge is angry at me.
I'm stripped down from my humanity.
I'm reduced to being just a prisoner.
I'm 22 and I smell like prison.
The prosecutor asked
for three years in jail for me.
My crime is considered to be severe,
and it means that the judge
can give me up to seven years in jail.
And as I'm standing here
handcuffed behind the bars,
I’m thinking to myself:
Can one person change the world?
Is it even worth trying?
Or am I just setting myself
up for failure?
Will I be able to achieve my dreams
or I'm going to be inevitably
smashed by the system?
I ran away from home
when I was 16 years old.
I jumped on a plane,
went from Siberia to Moscow.
I was 16 and I was a dreamer.
And I knew that I want two things in life.
I want to be able to dream wildly
and to be able to make
my utopian dreams come true.
For that, I knew I needed to be in Moscow.
I was studying philosophy
and I was stealing food
and clothes in order to survive.
When I turned 22,
I got arrested for resisting to one
of the most dangerous dictators
on planet Earth.
At the day of my arrest,
my daughter turned four.
You can sit down if you want.
What is my crime exactly?
I sang a song.
"Virgin Mary, please get rid of Putin."
Me and four other members of Pussy Riot
came to Cathedral of Christ the Saviour,
and we preached to the people of Russia
from the holy place that
for thousands of years
was reserved only for the male preachers
and, in particular, for the patriarch
of the Russian Orthodox Church,
who today sends Russians
to kill and to die in Ukraine.
We sang our song
on February 21 of 2012.
We did it in response
to Putin's announcement
that he wants to rule Russia
pretty much indefinitely.
I dropped everything I was doing,
and I promised to myself
that I'm going to dedicate
my life to resistance.
I felt deep inside me
that Putin equals death,
medieval torture,
knife in the back, stagnation,
new Dark Ages for Russia.
To resist, we used our loud voices,
bright ski masks, dresses, courage,
commitment and performance art.
We would show up in public places,
unannounced, guerrilla style.
No permits at all.
And perform, preach.
We performed in government buildings,
squares, shopping malls,
and we would get arrested
almost every single day,
get out and go back to action.
Our job was to show the people of Russia
that resisting is indeed an option.
The supreme, sacred,
holy rule in Putin's Russia
is to remain afraid.
We decided to break this rule.
By breaking this rule,
we disrupted the game as such.
We exposed it as a mere game.
We said that the emperor is naked.
Did we achieve what we wanted?
As I'm standing behind
the bars, handcuffed,
I'm asking myself this question.
Yes and no.
As I said in my closing statement,
we are behind the prison bars,
but we are freer than people
who are prosecuting us
because we can say whatever we want to say
and they can say only things
that the government censorship
allows them to say.
Despite of the global movement
in support of Pussy Riot,
we got convicted to two years in jail.
The hell was in front of me.
I was forced to sew
police and military uniforms
and I was getting injured
while I was doing it.
But even in the darkest moments,
I knew that our fight is not over.
Two years later,
I will get out of jail.
And I will meet thousands
of young Russians
who will tell me that they got
inspired by our fight.
Over the next ten years,
Pussy Riot will build
infrastructure, tools
and network for effective resistance.
In 2014, we started Mediazona.
It's unique in Russia, free of censorship,
[an] independent media outlet.
In 2022,
we raised seven million dollars
in two days for Ukraine.
When reproductive rights became
under attack in the United States,
we raised close to one million dollars
for Planned Parenthood.
We started Unicorn DAO
and raised two million dollars
to collect art made by women
and non-binary people.
I really wish I could tell all of this
to a 22-year-old version of myself
that is standing behind the bars,
separated from her family,
not knowing what's going to happen next.
Much work remains to be done.
My friends and family are getting beaten,
imprisoned,
poisoned,
tortured and murdered back home.
In March 2023,
I was put on Russia's most-wanted list.
I'm facing new criminal charges
for the art I made.
Why?
Because I said that the emperor is naked
and because he is, in fact, naked,
he's scared of it.
We shattered the world of appearances
and we said that living a lie
is indeed living a lie.
And it's dangerous for any dictatorship.
The reason why I became
a threat to the system,
not because of any actual
physical power that I have,
but because courage is contagious.
And any act of speaking the truth
can cause incalculable transformations
in social consciousness.
And we all have this power.
It's a moral act to use this power.
You may or may not
achieve the results that you wanted,
but there is eternal beauty
in trying to find truth,
in risking everything you've got
for what's right,
stop calculating your profit
and just taking a leap of faith.
Courage is an ability to act
in the face of fear.
And some of us
have chosen to live courageously.
For some of us, it's not a choice.
It's a matter of survival,
like for our Ukrainian friends.
Vladimir Putin became intimidated
by Ukraine choosing the path
of freedom and democracy.
That's why the Russian army bombs
maternity wards, schools, hospitals,
rapes and kills civilians
and throws their bodies in mass graves.
Putin and everyone who supports him
are dead inside and they must be defeated.
And while I'm standing here,
I want to send a message
to Vladimir Putin directly.
A wanted criminal to wanted criminal.
Vladimir Vladimirovich,
the Kremlin walls
became your prison walls.
You have already lost.
You know it.
That's why you're so afraid.
You lost in spirit.
The world is on Ukraine's side.
The world is with the brave
people of Ukraine.
And in your final hour,
when you pray
to whoever you're going to be praying to,
know that she is on our side.
She's on the side of truth.
(Applause)
And she's not going to forgive
your crimes against humanity.
Yesterday, my friend,
my colleague and comrade
Vladimir Kara-Murza
was sentenced to 25 years in jail
for publicly condemning the war in Ukraine
and Vladimir Putin's regime.
He said in his closing statement,
"I know that the day will come
when the darkness engulfing
our country will dissipate.
This day will come as inevitably
as spring comes to replace
even the frostiest winter."
And I'll finish my speech with words
of ... 22-year-old version of myself.
I said in my closing statement,
"Passion,
openness and naivete
are superior to hypocrisy,
cunning and contrived decency
that conceals crimes.
(In Russian) Open all doors,
take off the epaulettes,
feel the smell of freedom with us.”
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)